et de mana cour de cassation se
prononcera sur un autre dossier celui de
patrick dils condamné en 89 pour un
double meurtre d'enfant mais le doute de
l'erreur judiciaire plane sur cette
affaire et demain patrick dils aura s'il
bénéficiera d'un nouveau procès dans ce
cas il pourrait retrouver la liberté
après 14 ans de prison dont confrères de
nancy st mathieu et ifk mnr se sont
rendus chez ses parents d'où ils ont pu
s'entretenir avec lui par téléphone
leur reportage celui dont tout le monde
parle depuis des mois celui qui
jusqu'ici ne s'est exprimé que par
téléphone c'est lui patrick dils il a 31
ans et il a surtout la particularité
d'avoir passé la moitié de sa vie en
prison
quatorze années derrière les barreaux il
a été condamné à perpétuité en 1989 pour
le meurtre de deux enfants meurtre qu'il
avait d'abord avoué puis signé aussitôt
dans quelques heures la décision rendue
d'ici par les magistrats de la cour de
cassation pourrait bouleverser sa vie
tout à l'heure patrick dils par
téléphone nous a confié ses impressions
je suis également confiant mais la
sérénité et la confiance il empêche pas
assez longtemps
le stress angoisse et puis la nervosité
bref que l'on n'a jamais été aussi
proche du but et puis c'est vrai que les
dernières heures sont extrêmement durs à
vivre c'est l'angoissé qui m'angoisse
appelé l'histoire de la liberté c'est
uniquement ça logique voudrait que fils
au jt vicat ce procès qu'il remette en
liberté soit pas dépassé pendant 14 ans
derrière les murs en étant innocent et
là-dessus j'affiche là plus rien qui
peut effrayer
y'a plus rien ses parents l'ont bien
compris
cette fois ci c'est la dernière chance
ils ont pourtant de bonnes raisons
d'espérer car il ya quinze jours
l'avocat général a requis son maintien
en détention certes mais aussi la
révision de son procès
l'heure est donc venue de décider
décider si oui ou non dans ce dossier la
présence et les révélations de francis
heaulme constitue un élément nouveau de
nature à faire naître un doute sur la
culpabilité du condamné
quoi qu'il en soit si patrick dils était
libérée ce serait une première dans les
annales de la justice française et la
reconnaissance d'une très grosse erreur
judiciaire